what happened with your recent article
so the short answer is that our recent
article has been retracted by the
publisher of the journal
archives of sexual behavior where it was
published
retraction is something I've never had
an article retracted before and it's
something that I've associated with
terrible things like
fraud
plagiarism
grievous mistakes
none of that
is true about our article
uh
frankly and honestly our article was
retracted because of the ideas and the
evidence it presented that angered
transgender activists and their allies
who pressured the publisher
who either agreed with them
based on politics or
chickened out or were worried about
business concerns I can't read their
mind obviously
but I will say that the retraction was a
sham
um I I would also say that
the retraction has
backfired entirely from their
perspective
our article has gotten far more
attention than it ever would have
the publisher Springer nature group
keeps metrics on this
our article has been downloaded almost
100 000 times which is
you know that's not perhaps a big deal
for
mainstream media but for an academic
article that is Extreme
uh we have received more news coverage
we're about
um
40 ranked 40 out of 400 000 articles of
about the same age in terms of media
coverage
here we are talking you know I'm on a
big podcast with you
uh and uh there have been articles and
so on so I'm not hurting uh I just want
people to
download
and read our article
and
don't pay attention to the retraction
notice it it's meaningless if people
want to get a hold of the now
forbidden article where are they where
should they go same place they ever did
our article was published Open Access
that means we actually had um funding
from society for evidence evidence-based
gender medicine
to um
published the article
for free reading you know most articles
academic articles have a paywall that
non-academics can't get through easily
there's no paywall
the retraction simply means
for practical purposes that Springer
stamped the words retracted article on
every single page
of the article
which it doesn't affect your ability to
read it and frankly I
uh where those words as a badge of honor
now that makes it kind of sexy it makes
it it feels like it's a top secret seal
so what's there's someone that's
listening that wants to go and search
what should they search for on the
internet in order to get this article up
in the right form
uh so
what I search in order to go to the site
to keep track on our current metrics you
know I'm really waiting for when we get
a hundred thousand dollar view I'm sorry
100 000 views
uh Diaz d i a z
Bailey b-a-i-l-e-y
rogd for Rapid onset gender dysphoria
which is what it's about
and then you'll have uh links to choose
from choose the one that says Springer
and that'll take you right to the site
you can read the article right there
okay so we flirted with it so far what
was in your forbidden study which was so
reprehensible that caused it to be
retracted and and stamped with a wax
seal
I'll
tell you in a moment but I just want to
give a bit of background
this article was
published by me and a co-author
Susanna Diaz
that is not her real name I don't know
her real name
she is the mother
of a gender dysphoric child whom she
believes has rapid onset gender
dysphoria which is rapid onset gender
dysphoria is something we need to talk
about I assume that your audience
doesn't necessarily know what it is it's
very important and it is the reason
why the trans activists came after us
reviton said gender dysphoria is
the explanation
of the surge
in
cases of gender dysphoria that has
happened over the past decade and
especially the past five years
the idea is this
a subset of
gender dysphoric cases and now it's by
far the greatest percentage
are adolescent
girls
who never showed any signs of gender
dysphoria in childhood they were not
tomboys they were not
masculine
they did however have issues
a lot of them had some mental health
problems they had some social problems
and so on
in adolescence
they tended to hang out with a crowd
that was unconventional and Progressive
and ideological
and they
got the idea
based on ideology that all of their
problems are due to underlying
transgender that they never knew of
before
they suddenly or rapidly announced or
they decided that they're transgender
and they announced to their parents and
many of these girls it's mainly girls
about three quarters
there may be some boys too but we should
talk about them separately
a lot of them are demanding very serious
treatments including Medical Treatments
they want
testosterone
which
has very serious
effects on the body and some of them
want surgery like
the amputation of their breasts
and some of them are getting this
our evidence in our article
is entirely consistent with that
we surveyed 1655
parents of Youth whom the parents
believed had this syndrome
three-quarters were
of the youth were girls
the parents said that indeed these youth
had
pre-existing
mental health issues and that the mental
health issues actually preceded any
indication of gender issues by four
years that's a long time
the
youth who were most likely
to socially transition now social
transition means
uh changing their pronouns changing
their style of dress changing
what they call themselves boy or girl
the youth most likely to socially
transition were the ones with the most
problems
that was also true for medical
transition which was
uh thankfully rare only about seven
percent
uh had sought meta or had obtained
medical treatment whereas about 60
percent had uh taken many steps to
social transition parents said after
they
socially transitioned they got worse
and the best what's his voice mean
they
became less happy they became
less
close to their parents
they decompensated
and the best predictor of transition was
uh that the family had received a
referral to a gender specialist
and if parents visited a gender
specialist they usually felt that the
gender Specialists pressured them to
transition their child
so there were some other interesting
findings too but those
were the ones that got
uh people upset and I think those are
probably the most important findings
because they are consistent with the
idea of Rapid onset gender dysphoria
rapid onset gender dysphoria was first
proposed by Lisa lippman who published
the first paper in 2018 she also
received
tremendous pushback
her the journal where she published her
article did not retract it but they did
make her make changes to her original
article and she suffered personal
consequences Brown University where she
was
cut off their ties with her
she you know she lost
contracts with Brown University
thank you
activists cannot stand the idea of Rapid
onset gender dysphoria
and I understand why
because it is threatening to their
belief system
they're strong they strongly believe
that
gender dysphoria is always real
and that the best
way to proceed is
to transition as quickly as possible and
furthermore that youth
are always right when they say
that they are gender dysphoric
that they're trans just believe them
all of these are contradicted by the
idea of
rapid onset gender dysphoria and our
study was strongly consistent
with
the existence of Rapid onset gender
dysphoria I will admit
that ours is only the second
major study of this phenomenon and
there's plenty of work to do and I don't
think that we've got this nailed shut so
that everybody is obligated to see this
world as we do
but it's an important study and
instead of trying to silence our
research it would have been better
if the skeptical had done their own
studies
to try to clarify what they thought was
going on
but of course
they didn't want to do that
see if I'm right with my conception of
this sort of two current explanations
for what's going on with regards to the
increase that we've seen over the last
10 years or so
one Theory posits that
the world's degree of acceptance of
trans people at large has changed it's
called the the left-handedness argument
uh online sometimes which is that uh
during the Middle Ages if you were
left-handed you were often accused of
being a witch or a wizard or something
and it would cause you to be ostracized
or sometimes killed or punished socially
in in some form or another which meant
that I think maybe only three percent of
people were left-handed during the
Middle Ages uh but then when
left-handedness is no longer seen as
wicked and it's socially accepted I
think the true number of left-handed
people is closer to maybe 12 let's say
so you see an increase in the number of
people who
identify as left-handed I suppose they
can be their true self their true
left-handed selves because there is no
longer social stigma attached to it
there is a camp that argues that the
rapid increase that we have seen in the
number of people identifying as
transgender over the last decade to two
decades or so has been due to this um
releasing of the glass ceiling and and
judgment by the group at large uh the
alternative Theory which is being put
forward is one of social contagion uh
that explains why females in particular
the F to M transition are particularly
susceptible to this females are more um
socially aware socially malleable and
influenced it's part of their sort of
intersexual competition and Status
um measuring uh apparatus that they have
a a greater susceptibility to Trends
around them because they are it's
important for them to room main part of
the tribe in that regard which would
explain or be part of the explanation
for why girls seem to be more impacted
by this uh ever increasing number it's
almost like a mimetic uh sort of
feedback loop that's occurring
how far away am I and what have I missed
in terms of that conception of the
landscape
you put it beautifully better than I did
so you should have got me on the paper I
could have been canceled as well yes
you're consider yourself a co-author on
future research uh well yeah actually I
can take it I I get enough stuff on the
internet as as it is already Okay so
what is
I first question is it impossible for
these two worlds to exist together is
there a blending of Rapid onset gender
dysphoria with the um activists theory
about about this is there a way that
those two worlds could co-exist
certainly
and I suspect they do it's it's a
question of which is predominating
uh obviously we become
much more tolerant of the transgender
fairly recently
I wrote a book in 2003 and people back
then thought that transsexuals were
really weird interesting but weird and
people were uncomfortable around them
now I think if anything they're thought
to be cool
uh and
I'm glad that
tolerance has increased
for the transgender
but I also think that it's important to
realize
that there may be trade-offs
I don't
think we need to be intolerant but I do
think that we need to be aware
that attitudes affect what people choose
to do
being transgender
is partly a decision that a person makes
take a very for example a very masculine
female
well she might decide well you know I'm
a just a masculine
teenage girl I like playing baseball you
know I'll just be a girl uh but or she
may say well gosh you know
I I could imagine being a boy Plus
you know I I get a lot of cred if I am
transsexual and
also really something we haven't
mentioned yet
which is happening which I think is
negative is The Binding up of
transgender identity and victim status
and I just think that
that's a problem with our uh world right
now that we're promoting victim status
not just among the transgender but all
kinds of phenomena and I just think it's
very negative
it creates a perverse incentive for
people to pedestalize things which are
actually negative in the long term
yes self-harm you know if self-harm
gives you a degree of prestige somehow
in whatever upside down barcel world it
is
there is now an incentive for people to
do a thing which there should be a
disincentive for them to do
so you there is social Renown now for
self-harm or for
um
uh mp uh multiple personality disorder I
don't know whether you saw on Tick Tock
last year there was a trend of people
um they would have that others I can't
remember what the word was it's like the
other the other versions of them would
would come out and I'm a this person and
I'm a that person
um which again you know
I'm pretty sure who was the guy that
created Eugenics who was the dude that
did it in the 1900s uh Francis Carlton
Francis Galton managed to make himself
go insane by worshiping a doll as a
deity right
my point being that you can you can
induce all manner of crazy psychological
maladies if you believe them hard enough
uh that I so I don't wanna
win on Galton because I don't know what
you're just talking about and I do know
Affair about
fair amount about Galton but what the
other thing that you said the key thing
is absolutely true and really important
and really fascinating that
if people believe
they can
enact all kinds of things and when I say
enact I don't mean they're pretending
exactly they're acting as if
they're acting in accordance with their
beliefs this is not the first go-round
for multiple personality disorder we had
an epidemic in the
uh early 1990s that was associated with
an epidemic of recovered memories of
sexual abuse this was
young women typically who went to
therapy with a therapist who believed in
this
who persuaded these women that their
fathers typically
had sex severely sexually abused them
repeatedly over years despite
these women never having any
uh memory of this and of course these
memories
these recovered memories were false they
didn't happen
in a subset of these women
also came to believe that they were
multiple personality disorder
and I I think that this what's happening
now with rogd rapid onset gender
dysphoria is
uh the same thing and the women that the
the big difference is that the girls
this is happening to
are getting it younger 14 15 16 instead
of 24 25 26 and they're getting it from
their peers rather than a therapist
otherwise I suspect uh the same kinds of
people are involved at both epidemics
both times why
why would it be the case that that uh um
psychological risk factors like OCD
autism spectrum disorder and a few
others why would they be predictive
of rogd
autism gets thrown around a lot as very
common
I I am not as impressed as many people
are by the evidence for autism
for one
the diagnosis of autism
has become so vague I don't even know
what it means anymore it's
become quite over diagnosed
um are the youth in our study did have
an excess of
formal diagnoses but they were very
general anxiety and depression
um why would
women with these emotional problems have
this susceptibility
I'm not sure the
1990s epidemic these were
somewhat older individuals and so they
had
more time to get accurate diagnoses and
the number one Associated diagnosis was
borderline personality disorder which is
associated with identity disturbance not
knowing exactly who you are what you
want to be being manipulative being
prone to extreme emotions
now
do I have an explanation why
it's they who
are most susceptible to these false
ideas I don't think I do I don't think I
do
I had a conversation with David Geary a
couple of months ago and uh David lucky
you fascinating guy absolutely
fascinating phenomenal episode
and one of the things that I learned
when speaking to him he was the first
person that introduced me to the concept
of Rapid unset gender dysphoria
um the group
that uh the another ideology that would
be associated with some of the people
who seem to be suffering rapid under
gender rapid unset gender dysphoria
would be a denial of biological
differences between men and women
the fascinating thing that's oddly sort
of recursive and cyclical and almost
ironic if it wasn't so
um odd is that the very reason that we
have a sext difference in the number of
f to M transitions is precisely because
of the biological difference between men
and women
it is the biological difference between
men and women that predisposes these
very goals to the increased
susceptibility of transition and that's
the same group that is denying it so
it's both the supply and the demand and
the denial it kind of all rolled up into
one do you know what I mean yeah they
have a very uh strange set of beliefs
that are mutually contradictory for
example they they believe in the idea of
innate gender identity that may be
hidden and so on but if it's an innate
gender identity then
and that men usually have one and women
usually have another
that's got to be a biological difference
uh yeah I I
think that their science is
not very
coherent scientific I don't I don't
think that's going to be a very uh
useful way to persuade them
what are the given you've had this
relative Landmark study you know one of
only two massive end size of whatever it
was
1655 pairs
1655 parents according on each parent
reporting on a child of theirs yeah yeah
um
what what do you what are the
implications of this moving forward what
have you thought about sort of next
steps and such
well our my next step I'm a you know I'm
an academic I'm a researcher I'm not a
clinician
I think that we need to get uh better
and more detailed
evidence and I'm involved in
what I think is going to be a really
important
study that is about to launch this
summer it's in collaboration with Lisa
Lipman who is the person who first
studied rapid onset gender dysphoria and
Ken Zucker who is one of the world's
leading experts in gender dysphoria
all three of us have
been canceled at least once uh so we're
the
collaborate canceled collaborate
collaboration but uh we also are experts
who are unafraid to stay in here
we're in this study we're going to be
recruiting both
gender dysport adolescence directly and
their families
and we have a very extensive survey
about you know mental health and gender
feelings about gender history of gender
steps taken toward transition and so on
uh we hope to enroll thousands and we're
going to follow these people up over
five years at least
to see how they turn out and to see how
that affects happiness
are the ones who transition going to
eventually be happier than the ones who
didn't
for example that's that's a big question
fascinating yeah fascinating I suppose
it's one of those things where
um
being able to spin explanations without
a scientific backing can be done at
lightning speed but being able to test
the hypotheses with science is actually
a pretty arduous task so you are always
going to be playing catch up behind
whatever the wake is that's left in
terms of people's bro signs
that's exactly right
we sometimes have been frustrated
ourselves the scientific process
is slow in part for bureaucratic reasons
we have to be very careful to get ethics
approval for this which by the way was
the reason
the ostensible Reason Not the true
reason the ostensible reason why
my latest article was retracted what's
the story there what what was the reason
that they gave you
the reason was this
Susanna Diaz is not an academic
she just went ahead and put up a survey
she's allowed to do that
she's allowed to publish such a survey
I am an academic
I have constraints any research that I
do I have to get approved by something
called an Institutional review board IRB
for ethics
now the data we're already collected
it's too late to go through IRB I
checked with my IRB and they said well
she didn't have to
and
you seem to be okay
being a co-author on this
but Susanna have not done this very
legalistic thing
that was a conventional
informed consent which is basically
this is exactly what you're going to be
doing do you consent
that is what Springer
said was lacking that's why they
retracted the article here's why that's
ridiculous
she made it very clear to parents what
the survey was about
they agreed by actually completing the
survey
the last line of the survey said we're
going to publish this online when we get
enough data and that's something that
Springer also said she said you didn't
tell them
that their data were going to be
published well of course they want this
published they believe these parents are
sick
of rogd being
shoved to the side being silenced that's
part of the reason why they wanted to
participate in the first place
so that that's the reason they gave I
don't believe it for a second but you
know in our new research that we will be
launching soon we went through all the
IRB uh procedure we are so covered that
uh there's not going to be any chance of
any problem like that
moving on to some of the other work that
you've done what is the typical sexual
orientation of
F to M and M to F people who identify as
trans
well I want to start with
what was typical
20 years ago
and
before which which was
pretty well established
back then most f2ms that is NATO females
who wanted to come
Men first of all they were
adults before they were able to achieve
that there was no
transitioning of children or even
adolescents
almost all of the female to males were
female attracted
or in the vernacular of sexology
homosexual female to male transsexuals
though about 10 percent
were attracted to men
for male to female
these are natal female I'm sorry natal
males who want to become women there
were two types
the first type was
the the type perhaps we are most
familiar with the kind that comes to
mind immediately it would be a a male
who was feminine from early childhood
little boy who wanted to be a girl
who became an adolescent who was
basically a girl and then when he could
get surgery he did in adulthood
that type was male attracted
and
sexology called that a homosexual male
to female transsexual
uh Jazz Jennings
I don't know if you know who Jazz
Jennings is she's a reality TV show
I
have considered her that type though I'm
less sure now for
uh various reasons but the other type is
at least as common but it is quite
unfamiliar because
nobody talks about it and it is
otagonophilic male to female
transsexualism
otagonophilia is a sexual
orientation I guess
whereby
a man is sexually aroused by the idea of
being a woman
most of these
natal males are attracted to other
people in the world and they're
attracted to women
but they are also attracted to and
sometimes much more attracted to a woman
that they create inside themselves
it starts
typically in adolescence where they
will put on their mother's panties and
bra look at themselves in the mirror and
masturbate
fetishistic cross-dressing
many of them will have fantasies about
having breasts in a vulva
and some of them will actually do what
they need to to get those
aragonophilia is very controversial
because
trans activists have tried to
sweep it under the rug
they're embarrassed by it I'm not I I
don't judge these people
also
many aragonophilic
transgender
persons
it experience the theory as a
narcissistic injury because it really
means a lot to them
to think of themselves as like women
but the theory says
they're not like women
they're men with this weird sexuality
and so that hurts their feelings
so I published a book in 2003 called the
man who would be Queen and uh as only
about
a third of the book
was about
adult transsexualism including
aragonophilia and the trans activists
back then
a few of them got so mad at what I wrote
that they tried to ruin my life
uh briefly I thought they might
uh
but you know they did back then uh what
is happening to our paper now they they
caused a Streisand effect so
more and more people
have heard about agonophilia including
persons with autogenophilia and I want
to stress that many of the many
aragonophilic males are great people
in my experience if they are open and
honest
they're admirable I have many
aragonophilic followers on Twitter
I have some autographic friends
and so on
and these people
are angry
at the activists who have tried to
censor any discussion about agonophilia
it has
prevented us from knowing
things like the best way that
aragonophilic individuals should live
their lives
should they transition should they not
transition
we don't know the study studies haven't
been done because
people haven't even felt free to ask the
questions
is there a
natal female equivalent have you ever
come across anyone
that is the opposite of Auto gynophilia
this is controversial
and that should be that should be the
preface for every single sentence that
you say this is controversial I would
say scientifically I don't think anybody
is politically upset about this at least
yet
give it time so the word for that would
be Auto androphilia
and
I know
um
transgender
uh persons who insist
that there really is
Otto androphilia
there's a guy who named Phil Illy
IL
Phil Illy i l y I think he's about to
publish a book called Auto
heterosexuality
very smart guy
but he believes that Otto endoraphilia
occurs commonly among transgender
females
I am less convinced you know I'm I'm
being a hard ass
scientist you know I
maybe but I I kind of doubt it because
male and female sexuality are so
different
aragonophilia is something that requires
a male type
sexuality which is very focused and
fixed
and strong
and aragonophilia occurs kind of
sporadically a a male finds out on his
own and becomes even though he's never
heard of it before
it dominates his early sex life
and I'm really
kind of skeptical that that happens in
NATO females but we'll see does that if
someone and if it's common
that somebody that's never heard of it
before kind of stumbles upon this thing
this particular
interest this orientation
does that suggest that there is a
biological
disposition precursor
I would bet
more money than I have that we will
find that eventually I think
aragonophilia is strongly biological now
can I prove that no
but
what is going to make
a 14 year old boy decided to put on his
mother's panties and go into the
bathroom and look at himself and become
aroused and so on
nobody teaches him that you know there's
a lot of it I should hope not yeah yeah
there's a lot of interest now especially
among uh gender critical types about uh
something called Hypno porn which
is
it's a type of pornography consumed by
gynophilic males and they're saying that
this porn is creating Aragon affiliate
well I don't believe it I I feel like
these guys have this interest and
they're finding the porn I I don't think
anything plausibly is going to
raise this idea in somebody that doesn't
already have the interest
the other word that I learned when
looking at some of your work is gynandro
morphophilia
one of the longest words I think I've
ever said in my life what's
gynandromorphophilia
morphophilia so I'm gonna say a word
that I I think is fine but uh
some people are touchy about it
gyneamorphophilia is sexual attraction
to females
what I mean by a is a NATO male
trans woman who has both breasts and a
penis still
um
you know I I assume I can say I can I
can see it in my mind's eye yep well
it's not hard to find it
online that that is a kind of
pornography I have come across
and it actually is uh quite a common
form
of pornography and even I think just
plain old normal straight men
get into that sometimes
but they're they're different than the
kind of men who need that and prefer it
and for example I had a
I had a girlfriend
at one time whose ex-husband
uh
had that preference and in order for
them to have sex
they needed to bring a picture of a
on the computer screen so he
could look at it
and become aroused
that became a problem for her I can
imagine I can imagine that that would
create complications yes yeah but that's
you know some other
just plain old I think mostly just plain
old straight men
they just I think don't have the hang up
about the penis being there too
this is what you know back in the 90s
you know on Alan Partridge which is a
famous British comedy show one of his
friends it turns out was going to
Thailand and he comes back and all he
wants to hear about is the ladyboys he
did all he wants to hear about is
ladyboys tell me about the lady boys he
keeps on saying yeah
that's right the lady boys that's that's
what they are yeah they still tour as
ladyboys of Bangkok in the UK I don't
know if that's the same in the US but I
mean there's posters everywhere for
ladyboys of Bangkok to my knowledge they
don't come here but um
you know there there are
female
escorts that you can find online
um I I knew
in writing my book uh the 2003 book
called The Man Who Would Be Queen I
actually at that time knew some
transsexual
uh
prostitutes
some of whom had worked
as she male prostitutes and then they
got surgery and continued to work
as female prostitutes
um opening opening up to as many markets
as possible yeah yeah well the one that
I'm thinking of
preferred the um
the men who liked women to the men who
like females
I I think she thought that the ones who
liked shemales
I don't know that they treated her
differently as as a very interesting so
this is this is a an obvious uh
follow-up which is
is this a new category of sexual
orientation are these people closer to
gay people or are they closer to
straight people
great question and so I can answer the
second part of that question they are
very close to straight people they're
not at all gay guys guys who get into
shemales
so if we bring these guys in the lab and
we show them pornography featuring just
women and the the kind that we use in
this situation is two women
having sex with each other
female female porn and
male male male porn
and those are
the kind best kind of uh
stimuli because if somebody gets aroused
there's no
ambiguity about who they're getting
aroused by
um guys who are into shemales get
aroused to the females but not the males
but they get slightly more aroused to
videos
of two shemales getting it on
and that's a little different than
typical straight men who get more
aroused by two females
than two shemales but neither
gynamorphophiles nor
regular straight men get aroused to two
men getting it on right next next
obvious follow-up question to that is
I've heard you say that heterosexual
women are genitally indifferent
what does that mean
I I would say not just genitally
indifferent they're I think that they're
conscious feelings
are indifferent in the laboratory
to erotica
so
if we bring women into the lab and we
show them the cane same kinds of stimuli
two men having sex two women having sex
great women
showing indifferent pattern of genital
arousal they get equally aroused to both
by both
and they get and they say
they get equally aroused by both now
they don't get that aroused
psychologically they don't straight
women do not get as aroused to watching
either kinds of
erotic stimuli that I just mentioned as
either straight men do
or gay men do
but it is interesting that they seem to
show this
flat pattern lesbians in contrast do
show both a
genital preference and a subjective
preference
for female stimuli is the a vestigial
arousal among lesbians for men
lesbians do get more aroused by
male stimuli than they do to nature
scenes but what about do they get more
aroused to gay men than gay men do to
lesbians
these questions are hard to answer
uh these are the studies that we need
Michael these are these are the hard
yeah judging questions that we need well
they're hard to answer because the kinds
of
okay
apparatus that
you must use to measure genital arousal
in men differs from that that you must
use to measured in women and the best
evidence that we have
we've taken it out of
the genitals into the brain we've done
fmri scanning of
people
who looking at erotic stimuli
and it pretty much shows the same
patterns as the genital stuff does
and your excellent question I
I think I'm going to have to hold off
answering because I don't remember
that's fine so we kind of I remember I
um I had a conversation with
Christina Durante and she taught me
about a study where they brought
um
women into a lab and they sat them down
opposite uh two different guys one guy
was really nerdy and one guy was kind of
a bad boy leather jacket and sort of
like quaffed hair and stuff like that
and they analyzed the
verbal responses and the um physical
responses that women had to each of
these different men
now they had a oscar-winning film writer
Some award-winning film writer write the
script that the gentleman actor was
using so it's like you know if you were
going to cut the cool guys like if you
come with me I'll show you the best
night of your life and it's going to be
really cool but I don't really care so
it kind of it doesn't really matter so
much very very high status Prestige
Prestige Prestige uh whereas on the
other hand the other guy was something
else now the interesting thing is it was
the same guy
the same guy was playing both roles they
just styled him differently and his
mannerisms had been adjusted one of the
most interesting takeaways was
there was a a number of uh lesbian
female attracted women
who were in the study and when they
looked at their behavior with the lower
status man
it seemed relatively straightforward
when they looked at their behavior with
the highest status man even though they
had a self-report of not being attracted
to him and their verbal Behavior wasn't
particularly forthcoming their nonverbal
Behavior was much more flirtatious so
they were playing with their hair more
they were kind of leaning in they were
pouting a little bit more and what that
kind of
suggested to me which I think kind of
leads into some of your work is that
even for women who are not attracted to
men for a very long time men have been
The Gatekeepers to so much with regards
to survivability reproduction protection
resources Etc
that it feels like even
exclusively female attracted women
just keep this skill set in the locker
room somewhere where if they need to
deploy it because The Chieftains come
over and she's just finished up with her
girlfriend that nobody knows about
secretly in a cave somewhere that she
can still kind of
turn it on and I thought that that was
really interesting
that is really interesting I wasn't
familiar with that also I think that
lesbians
women who identify as lesbians are not
as exclusively
female attracted as gay men are male
attracted even if they
might deny that
lesbians are more likely than gay men to
become non-lesbian uh you know relapse
to go back yeah there's
uh a researcher named Lisa Diamond who
has studied something she calls female
fluidity which
refers to women's
greater propensity to
um
I don't know become romantically
interested in somebody regardless of
their natal sacks and not not all women
do this and there are some you know
let's say gold star lesbians who uh
would never uh go for a man but
I think there are more lesbians who have
the capacity
for sexual attraction to men okay so in
your opinion that is male sexual men's
sexual orientation is more fixed and
absolutions is more valuable absolutely
and that's that's part of the reason why
men but not women
not many women
have paraphilias which are these weird
sexual interests aragonophilia is a
paraphilia but some others
are for example pedophilia
sexual attraction to Children what's the
what's the amputee one what's that one
uh that is called acrotomophilia thank
you yeah
right yes which we've been studying
there's
um and and zoophilia attraction to
animals
uh lipophilia which is uh attraction to
morbidly obese people and the guys who
are into them tend to be just normal
weight guys
uh and we we just we have a paper that
is about to be published it's uh
accepted and I'm working on the proofs
now which I think is
he modestly says I think it's very
interesting uh but we studied we we
studied guys into amputees guys into
animals and guys into their really huge
fat people
and for each of these three kinds of
paraphilias
a lot of these guys also have the
inversion they are sexually aroused by
the idea of becoming yes right
a fat person an animal
uh which you know
and and I think we have about 10
guys into amputees who've actually
managed somehow to get amputations wow
so I first learned this from Dr James
canto
and spoke to him about it and and he
described it in this really lovely way
which was
um a lot of the sexual let's just call
it a lot of the paraphilias that people
have and and the odd fetishes that
people are turned on by
um is reflected both outwardly and
inwardly so there are people who are
attracted to amputees there are people
who see themselves as amputees they have
their limbs they have all of their limbs
but they feel like they should not they
feel like they shouldn't have that he
also uh I don't know whether you believe
that this is true said that there are
people who are attracted to children and
there are people who see themselves as
children there are men often who want to
be dressed up as babies we did the first
study of this Kevin my PhD student Kevin
Sue and I did a first study of Otto
pedophilia and
that's right uh and the most ethical
form of pedophilia yeah and one a really
interesting finding of that
um study was that men some of these men
are attracted to boys some are attracted
to girls
well the the guys who are attracted to
girls
are sexually aroused by the idea of
being a little girl
not a little boy which is interesting
um
so you have it that is a great way to
prove that the relationship outwardly
and inwardly is the same yeah because
otherwise you wouldn't have this
relationship between the two that's so
interesting why is everyone not a sex
researcher why is everyone not doing
paraphilia I feel the same way yeah so
interesting oh okay so in your opinion
does bisexuality truly exist in men like
how how accurate do you think the
stereotype is that bisexual women are
really straight and that bisexual men
are really gay
in I think it was 2005 we published a
paper
um
that failed to find evidence
that male bisexuality truly existed
where by that I mean that men in the
laboratory would show
arousal to both men and to women
uh that didn't did not make us popular
we were
um you know got us into the news but not
liked
we have kept studying this by we I and
my then graduate student now he's a
professor in England Gerald Rieger
and we've uh gotten
several hundred
uh
several hundred uh subjects in the lab
and uh two years ago we published in
proceedings of National Academy of
Sciences
a paper in which we
showed beyond the shadow of a doubt that
male bisexuality truly exists
um
there is a subset of bisexual men who
clearly produce arousal to male stimuli
and to female stimuli
most of them are somewhat more aroused
by one sex than by the other they're not
exactly until predominantly yeah gay or
predominantly straight bisexual man yeah
yeah but they are they're a bit bisexual
yes so I now
believe for sure in male bisexuality
at the same time
if you talk to gay men
ask just ask them this question did you
ever say you were bisexual
about half a gay men will say yeah
then you say well were you really
bisexual in the same no so it really
does
happen that
some men misrepresent
being bisexual but it also seems to
happen that some men are bisexual as I
would understand that understood but
it's a a small cohort and also you it's
difficult to stress test whether this is
the thin end of the wedge on route to
becoming a fully fledged member of the
gay community or whether you're actually
going to just stop at the letter B yeah
that's interesting
um
what what about environmental influences
on sexual orientation so we have at the
moment uh in Korea
a very sort of sex negative culture
which you'll probably be familiar with
where there is the four bees movement
women who are recanting I can't remember
what the four different bees stand for
it's in Korean uh but it's it's men and
patriarchy and family and work or kids
or something like that and it is
Downstream of a whatever less than one
birth rate and a kind of it's
everything's career is just a mess but
that seems like uh whether it be
outright celibacy abstinence or uh
turning to lesbianism I don't know
whether that's true
um that is a sexual orientation response
to an ecological or environmental cue
right something has happened that has
changed maybe the sex ratio maybe the um
make value of the potential available
partners that are around
Downstream from that we have declining
birth rates across the West too we have
a an increase in cohort of high
performing women and an increasing
cohort of underperforming men
hypergamously that means that maybe
women are going to be struggling to find
men that are of the make value that they
would desire even though we're in a
society which has been the most sort of
sex positive uh ostensibly than it's
ever been I think that there is a bit of
a sex recession going on there's a great
um uh article in the Atlantic about this
so with all of this folded together how
how malleable is sexual orientation in
response to the local environment and
could you foresee a future given where
we're at
sexually and with the mating crisis at
the moment that this could continue in
the future
this is another one of those times when
it's important to distinguish
male and female sexuality
and this is what I'm going to say is
speculative because
this hasn't been established and there's
a lot of disagreement
but my
gut sense is that
men's sexuality is not going to be
responsive
to
cultural pressure much
I I say much
because there are parts of the world
where men will have sex with other men
other males let's not call them men
if the males are presenting as very
feminine and perhaps transgender so for
example in Samoa there's a
NATO males who are considered a third
sex called the fafafina
and you got the ladyboys in Thailand and
so on it's pretty common for just plain
old straight men
to have sex with these NATO males now I
don't think that makes them gay
they're not having sex with men they're
seeing these people as female-like
but
I don't think there's anything
any kind of cultural change even if I
could build Society from the ground up
that would make
straight men
want to have sex with each other
uh
I think women are likely different and
more responsive to cultural factors
and perhaps also things like
um
bad experiences with men there's a uh
you know this belief
that uh one route to lesbianism is being
mistreated by men
we don't know that's true but I find it
plausible but I don't think that women
mistreating men is going to make them go
gay
no that's fascinating one thing that
I've been considering a lot is you've
been talking about the
thin line between what being gay means
physically
and what it means
in terms of appearance
you know there's an interesting question
is a very voluptuous big boob big lips
long hair
um
Thailand type presenting person
more female
than a very shaven head uh sort of more
androgynous body type
but
vagina owning
woman
and there's a really interesting
question going on here you know that you
highlighted there it is in Samoa it's
referred to as a third gender you know
there's a lot of um accusations from the
left of genital fetishism which you
might have heard of which is that you're
actually being uh you're addicted to the
genitals as opposed to the presentation
but
there is an interesting question given
that
our sexuality is so easily fooled we are
such rampant sexual beings that a six
inch by four inch screen
that has a small depiction of sex
happening on it is enough to fool our
brain to think
there's some sex happening here another
reason there was some sex happening
there a long time ago and now you can
see around the side of it you know that
it's not here you know that you're not
getting any of this and that that
illusion is responsible for the internet
correct correct yeah so
my point being that you you already
concede as soon as you accept the fact
that porn is an effective stimuli
you accept the fact that it is not
exclusively about the action it's about
the presentation right
is it just a difference of degree not a
difference of kind all the way down to
the more
female presenting regardless of whether
it's a XX or XY chromosome person
it really starts to blur the line
between what is and is not classed as a
same-sex or an opposite sex attracted
sexual orientation
yeah I think that all we have
for the most part are are senses or
and you know men especially but humans
in general are very visual species and
um you're absolutely right that some
trans women even those who still have a
penis
uh can look
uh White they look like really
attractive women
uh although often you can kind of see
the remnants of their maleness and their
bone structure or something like that
but
uh yeah I and I I think that
in those cases
men who don't feel
attracted to them or say they don't
that's more likely to be
mental you know some kind of aversion an
idea like that person is a man not a
woman so despite the fact that they look
like a really attracted woman I can't go
there
um
yeah it's so fascinating because I've
seen this you know I've seen this
argument happen on on
dating shows or on uh right-wing
commentary channels and stuff like that
around uh no because that would be gay
I'm like is it is it more gay to have
sex with what looks like a 9 out of 10
woman
body shape size voice presentation
actions everything with a penis
than it is to have the exact opposite
all of the presentation factors of a man
could be on testosterone could be all of
the rest of it but has a vagina that it
and it's a really really fascinating
question and you know this sort of
it falls in line with a number of other
arguments this sort of more biological
essentialism side of things especially
the people that would say
um unless you can change your
chromosomes and even not then if you're
a natal male I'm calling you a man if
you're a natal female I'm calling you a
woman for the rest of time
um so I it's a a suite of beliefs I
suppose all of which are interplay with
each other and would also Cascade down
from there but um yeah it's a really
really fascinating consideration around
what it means and this is when you get
into the
deeper and deeper into the layers of
paraphilia and the nuances of sexual
orientation it all kind of starts to
break apart it's like the quantum level
of of uh sex research I suppose
yes yes we we are going on the outskirts
here
um what about people's gaydars do you
think that most of us have an accurate
gaydar
yeah this is again something we've
studied quite a bit uh and yeah people
have a much better than chance
uh gaydar
now it's not perfect
but they are much better at than chance
at Discerning whether a man
is gay or straight and they
rely some gay men you know just their
outward appearance in the west currently
is not necessarily very feminine
although I I think gay men might
present themselves more attractively
than straight men but it's more things
like movement
you know
and speech speech patterns are yeah you
found that there's like a gay accent
there's a gay accent yes what is the gay
accent
yeah we so we we know it when we hear it
and and you know actors can often affect
the gay accent even if they're straight
uh there's interestingly there's a
lesbian accent too I I think a gay
accent May tend to be more expressive
and gay men articulate more clearly than
straight men and lesbians have the
opposite they're less expressive and
they don't articulate as clearly
do you think is that in any way gay men
modeling female speech patterns are
there any lot parallels there yeah you
ask great questions and the you know so
nobody knows and I I think there are two
at least two
good hypotheses there one is that
unconsciously growing up gay men
you know some of them they had
somewhat feminine gender identity and
they did model
uh the other is that there's something
about gay men's brain which is
somewhat feminized and produces this
speech pattern
nobody knows well when it comes to the
ability to present clearly my speech
coach that I use for the podcast is gay
uh classically trained in theater
classically trained in improv uh for not
just an outrageous communicator and
probably the best Communicator that I've
had on the show is Douglas Murray who is
also a him and Miles my speech culture
like two P's in a pod that I've never
met
um but just phenomenal like app
out of this world Precision with his
ability to
um remain cool Under Pressure to be able
to communicate in a very precise way to
be able to use
inflection and drama and Whimsy and to
then be able to pull it back without
being uh fragile just phenomenal and so
yeah I I wonder Andrew Doyle as well
saturis from the UK that runs the
Titania McGrath a Twitter account I
wonder I wonder whether um being gay is
a competitive advantage in the world of
online commentary perhaps
um but yeah it's all of that stuff's so
interesting and you write as well that
you kind of
I I don't think I've been around
sufficient lesbians to be able to say
that I would I could pick up on that
um the only real things that I ever
notice
with lesbians are sort of the into the
dress I think that uh lesbian lesbians
seem to dress significantly more
differently to normal women than gays
dudes yeah the the plaid shirts the
baggy jeans
um
yeah gay men uh dress somewhat
differently more stylishly at least it's
just better usually that's right that's
right
yeah very funny
what was that paper that you did about
male mate value being more malleable
than female make value
well that's an old one
um
yeah the student who was the lead author
on that was interested in the ex
explaining the sex difference in the in
depression women are more likely to get
depressed than
men are and she hypothesized that
it could be because
you know women's mate value is more tied
to
their looks which she said you can't
do that much about whereas men it's
their accomplishments which you can and
um and she got some evidence for that
I'm not sure that I that that's you know
an old paper and I'm not sure I believe
the theory because you know
if women if women really can't do that
much
uh about their looks what's the
cosmetics in Industry doing I mean uh
and you know it's it's not that easy for
a man to go out and double his income so
um
anyway but that that's what the paper
was about
yeah so I find I had a conversation with
Ed Hagen as well recently and Ed did a
study where they controlled for upper
body strength when looking at
differences in depression and anxiety
and when you control for upper body
strength the differences between men and
women
get smaller and smaller and smaller and
then essentially go away
um and the the reason that I was
interested in discussing uh malleability
of mate value is that it's it's a common
discussion that's had on the internet
and it's born out of a contest between
men and women about who's got it worse
it's like well it's easy for you because
you just need to go and get a boob job
but I can't make myself any tall taller
and women will say well it's easy for
you because you know at 21 I reach my
Peak sexual market value and it's all
downhill from there and you get to
continue to accrue status and resources
and it's very much sort of um
two people talking different languages
that
the
sexual brains the the sexual attraction
mechanism that works for men what they
want from women and for women what they
want from men are not the same it's not
you can't
play uh a balancing act there is no
ability to work out the equity there's
no exchange rate between these two like
how many boob jobs is three inches of
height worth do you know what I mean
like there is no way of us doing it oh
well you could wear high heels and put
makeup on but you can go out for five
years and increase your earning
potential by 40 like what does that even
mean when we're talking about this
um
I had a theory which I thought maybe
total horse so I'm gonna try and
bring it back up again I had a theory
that
um
male mate value to the individual
to the individual is more malleable into
the group is less malleable and female
individual make value is less less
malleable and to the group it's more
malleable that
you basically have as a man there are
more degrees of freedom that you can
move yourself on
and there is a longer timeline that you
can do it on specifically because of the
fact that you know a guy who's
35 is more attractive than a guy who's
25 to most women on average and I don't
know when that Peaks probably in your
mid to late 30s perhaps
um but even then you know Leonardo
DiCaprio has been acquiring and
disposing of under 25 year old
girlfriends regularly for like two
decades now
um so with sufficient status and and
resources you can continue to cycle
through that
um
but yeah what what do you what's your
mindset at now when it comes to
malleability especially with us facing
this mating crisis and and people having
concerns around uh being able to be seen
by the other sex
well I I think that
in the sense that I understand you I
think we're probably very malleable
the culture has changed tremendously
you know in a fairly short time and I
it's gonna
guessing it will change tremendously
still I hope it changes back in certain
ways because I'm not that happy with
certain things now
but that's a different question than do
I know how to change it I do not
um and that that
has to do with male male female
interactions as much as academic freedom
both of which well the latter concerns
me more now
Michael Bailey ladies and gentlemen
Michael I really really appreciate your
work any opportunity to dig into people
that are looking into sex is is
fascinating for me I've immensely
enjoyed talking to you I I hope that we
get uh
more chances either in person or back
here whatever I have a pleasure I have a
laundry list of things that we didn't
get to talk about to do with sexual
arousal patterns virtuous pedophiles uh
the birth order effect of homosexuality
so we can absolutely run this back let
me know once your new paper is out uh as
a reminder for the people who want to
check out your article and also follow
you online and stuff like that where
should they go where would you want to
direct them
I am a boring academic uh we you can
go to Google Scholar and search for J
Michael Bailey or there's something
called researchgate
where uh you can find lots of my papers
as well or email me
uh at my University address it's j m
hyphen Bailey b-a-i-l-e-y at
northwestern.edu and uh and I'll try to
help you if you need it uh yeah nothing
fancy for me Michael I appreciate you
thank you
thank you thank you very much for tuning
in if you enjoyed that episode then
press here for a selection of the best
clips from the podcast over the last few
weeks and don't forget to subscribe